yeah the reason these two boys came to
Thailand to visit and everything was
because I finally 100 in my wedding guys
I heard one is done
it's all done now all of the family is
appeased no one is complaining anymore
with everyone has had a chance to go he
has all the Collectibles I have I
literally have I collected them all now
everything everything
um but it's it's funny because
this uh we decided to do like a
traditional like of like a traditional
Thai ceremony we could have just had
like the reception everything like that
but my parents were like no
um we want to do the traditional Thai
ceremony just because you've never seen
it yeah so even though I'm like talking
like about the Thai ceremony and this is
your guys's first Thai ceremony it was
also my first Thai ceremony as well
that's interesting yeah yeah it was cool
like it was I don't know it was a lot
more I guess not free-flowing it's not
the right word I guess more casual than
I thought it was going to be because
like I'm because you know I've been to
like traditional Japanese weddings right
and that's like you know a 500 page
script that you have to follow right
yeah whereas like this one felt like
yeah like as you said it was a wedding
of course but it was more like just a
celebration of like family getting
together and just like shooting the [__]
yeah which I think I really appreciated
because like I was expecting it to be
like really super uptight and like very
formal and you know they were like
obviously very formal parts of it you
know like like the the Buddhist monk
thing was like super freaking cool yeah
um but then you know I had to do like 10
push-ups for you okay as well which was
weird yeah so two to explain everything
that kind of went down at this wedding
so uh normally you start off in the
morning and normally the morning is the
part where you do the serious kind of
blessings that's right uh we started off
at about like like before before
anything actually these two boys asked
me what do I wear do I do I wear a suit
or something like that or Thai yeah and
I was like no uh wear a Hawaiian shirt
Hawaiian shirts shorts and thongs
my language exactly I mean it's it's
hard enough in Thailand man we were like
no nobody wears suits we're going like
all casual the anyone who really wore
kind of a more traditional Thai attire
uh was me and Sydney so we had gotten
dressed early in the morning and even
then
what I wore in My Thai wedding compared
to what I wore in my you know other
wedding uh in England was a lot less
layers it was just one kind of like
traditional Thai suit yeah and like very
very airy and baggy pants is how I
looked cool they were actually really
comfy yeah I kind of like after I like
they I had the opportunity to get
changed earlier in the day but I was
like I don't like this I kind of like
this ride now it looks really cool yeah
yeah
um but one thing I kind of like wasn't
prepared for actually was uh uh this was
like my the only time that I had got my
makeup done yeah I noticed you're
wearing makeup and I was like wow God
looks like he's been airbrushed yeah
okay yeah is wearing makeup like a
traditional thing or is that sound like
your mom was like hey I got you hooked
up honest you look like as [__] bro let
me fix it yeah I think I think uh for
Thai weddings you they most people
wanted to look as good as you can in
photos and everything like that but the
difference is most people don't trust
themselves some make themselves look as
good as they can
um so my mum hired like a makeup artist
and then the day before she was like Oh
no you're getting your makeup done as
well I'm like what what do you mean I'm
getting my wake up done and uh so yeah I
got my makeup done I think God damn it's
I gotta says he was eyebrows on fleek
girls
respect to you girls man holy [__]
makeup is uncomfortable oh that was
awful wait so you got just like I think
you got like your cheeks done and like
your eyes a little bit and the lip gloss
as well the lip gloss was the thing that
like annoyed me the most oh yeah yeah
you look like an ad
yeah so I got I got ready and got my
makeup done in the morning and then the
monks came at around 10 o'clock um
um and their ceremony they're you know
praying blessing ceremony lasts for
about 30 minutes to 45 minutes and
basically they kind of just pray and
give their blessings and everything like
that I mean you've always
yeah well they started uh singing that
was pretty hype it was a challenge yeah
that was [__] cool it was so cool
yeah because I I remember we were having
this like ceremony and obviously
Sydney's parents and family were there
as well and uh my dad was like oh the my
my uh Sydney's mum and dad was like oh
that was such a beautiful part to uh
such a beautiful ceremony to be a part
of thank you for inviting us and showing
us part of your culture and everything
and then Sydney's uncle was also there
and he just goes to me man those monks
got bars
I was like yeah yeah but it's it it
makes sense it makes sense because
um I didn't realize this when I was
because you know I've been a monk and
everything like that I didn't realize
this but there's a certain Rhythm
rhythmic quality wow when they are
praying and everything uh because you
know there's how it works is there's
normally one head monk that starts off a
verse let's say and they they say a few
sentences they chant a few sentences of
this verse and then everyone else joins
us afterwards yeah and it's kind of it
the whole reason why Buddhist monks pray
is not because we're praying to a god or
anything like that because we don't have
a God in Buddhism but it's it's kind of
to get us in the rights mindsets
to meditate to be a monk and everything
and with I kind of realized after
talking to Sydney's mum and dad why
the prayer kind of has this effect
because when you're praying when you
have that kind of rhythmic prayer going
on for like an hour sometimes your mind
kind of goes into this hypnotic stance
States it's like a trance it's like a
trance yeah kind of and then that gives
you that gets you into the right mindset
to live the monk life and to meditate
afterwards as well
um and yeah I think it's I'm really glad
you boys got to experience it because it
can be like a very powerful experience
sometimes because that was we had 10
months in just my house but in a temple
uh especially when I was among we had a
we had a temple with a hundred monks
that sounds crazy yeah so you're in
you're in the temple when this massive
hall and then yeah you hear the you hear
the head monks start praying and in my
mind in my temple we needed to know all
of the prayers by heart right so I
needed to memorize them so I need I knew
when when the head monk started starting
a line I would know when to come in and
I would know when to start praying as
well and you all join in and the
ambience and the sounds that just
vibrates throughout the entire Temple
it's something like some something I
can't really explain via words but it it
feels really really powerful oh yeah
even even just with the 10 monks in in
your house like it was yeah I mean like
it just if the fact that everyone was
just you know very silent and a lot of
us were like closing our eyes and you
know
um just trying to like take it all in it
was like yeah I don't know it felt very
otherworldly you know it was uh because
you know because Japan has a similar
thing as well yeah and like funerals and
stuff like that uh but yeah every time I
hear I don't know what it is every time
I hear that sound it just puts me like I
can just feel my body floating away if
that makes sense you know it's just
something about it and you don't even
have to like know the words yeah at all
either I mean they're not even speaking
Thai oh really it's like it's uh I think
the language is like Sanskrit I don't
know what the English translated name of
it is but it's it's like an ancient
language so okay yeah they're not
actually they're not actually chanting
Thai it's uh it's a more older language
which is why you need to memorize it
right um which is why I need to memorize
it because I don't actually know what to
say what they're saying it's it's an
basically I I would say it's more
equivalent to them chanting Latin if we
were in like European language right
yeah I was trying to figure out when
when I was supposed to pray I was like
everyone's face in their eyes okay okay
yeah
so because I want to be respectful yeah
guys just sitting there while I'm still
like I'm like all right well yeah yeah
even I don't personally you know believe
in it yeah I still like to respect
anything culture especially if they're
inviting me yeah no it was yeah I
remember that actually it was so funny
because you know when they started
chanting and you know most people in the
room were you know signed to pray yeah
and and I joined in and I remember
halfway through I looked up and your mom
is just standing there with
I think this is like a South Asian
Southeast Asian thing where like yeah
moms and ants just seem like Unstoppable
and like it's like no matter what is
happening they will be doing what they
want to do yeah
it could be like the most important
thing ever and they'll be like guys get
closer I'm taking a shot you know it's
like whoa It's like what oh we don't
know it's not like a religious thing
it's such a power move no I'll I'll
definitely get to that point because I
being there definitely reminded me of
one thing uh which I'll get back to but
um yeah one at the moment at the
beginning I was trying to like tell
Sydney everything that she had to do
everything she could expect with the
monk thing and then when when the monks
got there I'm just like just follow my
lead Sydney there's too much going on
because there's one thing I forgot to
tell her about which is at the end
um we light a candle uh for the Monk and
the monk like melts this wax onto like a
bowl of water which they will then kind
of like spray onto US oh yeah right
um I knew this was going to happen
because there's uh what do I call it
like I'd not exactly spray but there's a
bunch of like sticks bundled up together
that will they will dip into the water
they will pray bless the water then can
I flick it into like the onto the crowd
sprinkle yeah like sprinkle sprinkle uh
Sydney didn't know this uh I I knew this
was coming so I've done this ever since
I was a kid and I and so I knew when
when the when you when the monk is about
to kind of uh spray everyone just
put your head down Sydney Sydney didn't
know this so she was she was just
praying in like a very nice kind of
mindset gets a face full of water from
the market
I think it's like we were we were kind
of in the back of the whole thing when
it happened and of course none of us
knew that was coming either so I'm just
like you know silently closing my eyes
and praying and then I get the AOE
splash down
and I'm like is this a test like is it
am I am I supposed to just like remain
calm and then everyone's just getting
like splashed you didn't get it at all
right no I didn't I heard like didus and
you kind of make a noise yeah cause I
was behind you so I didn't get anything
like that yeah so you're you're in uh
you're you're in the spot yeah
that's a wide AOE dude oh my God